tender kneepads you know how sometimes
life seems like you're you're living
years in a couple minutes this is me and
I we're identical I kind of take pride
in being one of very few identical twin
pairs that are boy and girl when I first
learned that that my child was
transgender I could I couldn't I
couldn't speak the word I was so I
didn't know I didn't know anything about
it and here I was this you know good
mother that researched everything before
we you know bought a diaper I mean I
wasn't me I just I I was the one in the
know and all of a sudden I didn't know
anything and it was frightening and it
was other and and I didn't want my child
to hurt or be hurt or be judged
I think people are fascinated by gender
reassignment surgery they're like
insatiably curious about it but they
also don't know how to have a
conversation about it people ask me that
question all the time you're like there
were no gender norms in this world like
but would any want to transition I'm
like well we do live in a world of
gender norms so don't quite see how it's
relevant
absolutely very honored to be the parent
accompanying a me on this journey feels
very sacred this time of stillness and
transition and embracing of this new
life and we've been kind of giddy entire
Oh nervous
they're gotta give you thanks for this
incredible girl
please bring this courageous girl
through today the name of your son Jesus
- been hurt - homeless a body mind and
spirit
[Music]
Caleb the story yeah I just talked it to
me
I asked him to record me a song is that
really about last night so he did that
for me and it's one of my favorites of
his and it has a lot of not to do with
overcoming the chorus girls think it's
light though there's miles to go oh
never back down keep walking through the
snow I hope that you find them I hope
you do tell them how I kept you warm
tell without tears love have no regrets
I married us inside the store the glans
penis becomes clitoris the skin of penis
becomes the labia minora and part of the
opening
the vagina the scrotal skin is taken off
and used as a skin graft it's rolled up
into a tube and that's placed in a space
that we make at the base of the scrotum
and goes back in between with bladder
sets and the rectum sits and that's
going to be the lining of vagina the
testicles and the cords are removed and
the urethra is actually saved in a flap
of urethra is used to make a hood for
the clitoris keeping you warm and dry oh
I may die here you'll follow through
[Music]
she's scared I can see it in her eyes
today but I know she's gonna be fine she
had a great surgery so when people don't
do well after their transition it's
because they have absolutely no support
system their support system is you know
like their family's putting on a game
face but you know they're scared as hell
too I mean those family members are real
heroes to me I have goose bumps as I say
this she's got everything going for her
hey it's me she's out she's great I know
I'm sorry I had taken like two days so
she's gonna be in in recovering a little
bit and she'll be a little groggy but
kind of taken care of by the gang here
and shall be ours again
I know that's Kate and we just went down
to the oh our I'll keep you in the loop
as I get any news so wish I could be
with her and Patrick sent three hearts
and Sara said thank you thank you in the
heart
jewel sent 300 and Laura said thank you
Kate
TSM Thank You Sophie girl I wish so much
being closeted was one of the worst
parts of my life being out of it I mean
it's not so much like a personal change
it's a social change I came out on
Facebook there was a lot of positive
just response just from that the thing I
really remember about coming out was I
was in a play I went to rehearsal they
were getting their pronouns right they
were using my name like it was you know
just a total different world and I felt
you know incredible if I was not out I'm
not sure I would like you know be alive
right now what my husband and I keep
we're marking on to each other is this
just feels so right it's so her it's so
the child we've always known and loved
even though a few years ago we wouldn't
have necessarily anticipated this step
when I think about why I eventually
wanted to get this surgery because I
really didn't at first I think the
reason that I that I ended up really
wanting it to happen started out as
being something more out of convenience
as it became more real and after I got
the surgery date and all of that I found
a million reasons you know why I wanted
it to happen
[Music]
and that's where I think transition is
again problematic because it presupposes
an end point like at some point you have
transitioned whereas every single one of
us is in constant development this is
obviously a huge huge moment in NME's
life but it's not the by any means the
endpoint is just in some ways the
beginning
[Music]
[Music]